- Selamat datang kembali ke Memahami Maklumat dan Pengiraan Kuantum.
Nama saya John Watrous dan saya adalah Pengarah Teknikal untuk
Pendidikan di IBM Quantum.
Ini adalah pelajaran ketujuh dalam siri ini dan dalam pelajaran ini kita akan bincangkan masalah anggaran fasa dan macam mana kita boleh selesaikannya
dengan komputer kuantum.
Kita kemudian akan terapkan anggaran fasa kepada masalah pemfaktoran integer, yang kita bincangkan dalam pelajaran sebelumnya.
Apa yang kita dapat adalah algoritma Shor, yang membolehkan integer difaktorkan pada kos polinomial atau dalam masa polinomial kalau kita nak
fikirkan dari segi masa yang diperlukan daripada bilangan
operasi asas yang kita perlukan.
Ini adalah permata mahkota
algoritma kuantum dalam erti kata tertentu, dan walaupun memfaktorkan integer besar
mungkin ada kegunaan yang terhad untuk kebanyakan orang, ia tetap jadi salah satu bukti yang paling meyakinkan yang kita ada untuk hipotesis bahawa komputer kuantum akan
menawarkan kelebihan yang menakjubkan
berbanding komputer klasik. Ni gambaran keseluruhan pelajaran.
Kita akan mulakan dengan definisi masalah anggaran fasa itu sendiri, kemudian kita akan bincang kaedah untuk selesaikan masalah ini
dengan komputer kuantum.
Kita akan buat satu langkah pada satu masa, bermula dengan apa yang boleh kamu
fikirkan sebagai semacam pemanasan.
Dalam masalah anggaran fasa, matlamatnya adalah untuk menganggarkan
suatu nombor nyata tertentu dan dalam bahagian pemanasan ini
kita akan tengok macam mana kita boleh dapat
anggaran ketepatan sangat rendah
untuk nombor ini.
Ini tak akan cukup bagus
untuk pemfaktoran bila kita terapkan penyelesaian kita kepada
masalah anggaran fasa untuk pemfaktoran integer,
kita sebenarnya perlukan anggaran ketepatan yang agak tinggi, tapi ia tetap berguna untuk mulakan dengan semacam pemanasan ni
cuma untuk rasa
macam mana keseluruhan benda ni berfungsi.
Kita kemudian akan bincangkan isu macam mana kita boleh dapat lebih ketepatan, dan ini akan membawa secara sangat
semula jadi kepada suatu operasi yang dikenali sebagai Transformasi Fourier Kuantum.
Kita akan tengok dengan tepat apa operasi ini dan macam mana ia boleh dilaksanakan
dengan quantum circuit.
Dan bila dah ada, kita akan dapat terapkan
ia kepada anggaran fasa untuk hasilkan prosedur umum untuk selesaikan masalah
dengan ketepatan sangat tinggi.
Kemudian dalam bahagian terakhir pelajaran, kita akan tengok macam mana penyelesaian kepada
masalah anggaran fasa membolehkan kita memfaktorkan integer dengan cekap.
Dan khususnya apa yang kita dapat adalah algoritma Shor untuk
pemfaktoran integer, atau sekurang-kurangnya sesuatu yang bersamaan dengan algoritma Shor.
Cara ni berfungsi ialah kita pada asasnya bagi
diri kita batu loncatan, yang merupakan satu lagi masalah yang dipanggil masalah pencarian tertib.
Dan khususnya kita akan tengok macam mana kita boleh selesaikan masalah pencarian tertib menggunakan prosedur anggaran fasa kemudian kita akan tengok macam mana
kita boleh memfaktorkan integer
dengan menyelesaikan masalah pencarian tertib. Kita akan mulakan dengan kes khas suatu teorem yang dipanggil Teorem Spektral,
dan khususnya kita akan fokus pada apa yang teorem itu beritahu
kita untuk matriks unitary.
Teorem spektral adalah
teorem yang sangat penting dari aljabar linear dan
analisis berfungsi.
Ia memberitahu kita sesuatu yang menarik tentang macam mana pemetaan linear tertentu boleh dinyatakan dalam bentuk tertentu, ia selalu dipanggil penguraian
spektral,
yang berguna untuk banyak sebab.
Dan macam yang saya cakap tadi, kita akan fokus pada apa yang teorem ini beritahu
kita untuk matriks unitary.
Teorem spektral adalah
lebih umum daripada ni. Ia tak berfungsi untuk semua matriks, tapi ia berfungsi untuk kelas matriks
yang dipanggil matriks normal, yang merangkumi semua matriks unitary serta beberapa matriks
yang bukan unitary.
Tapi cuma untuk buat perkara lebih mudah, kita akan hadkan perhatian kita
kepada matriks unitary buat masa ni sebab itulah sahaja yang kita perlukan untuk
tujuan pelajaran ini.
Ni pernyataan teorem spektral cuma untuk matriks unitary.
Andaikan U adalah
matriks unitary N kali N.
Apa yang teorem katakan
ialah mesti wujud asas ortonormal
vektor, psi satu hingga psi N,
bersama-sama dengan N nombor kompleks
Lambda satu hingga Lambda N, semua terletak pada bulatan unit kompleks supaya U boleh dinyatakan
seperti yang ada dalam persamaan ini.
Ini dipanggil penguraian
spektral U, macam yang dah saya sebut, dan ia boleh jadi sangat berguna untuk tahu bahawa U boleh ditulis dengan cara ni.
Kadang-kadang berguna untuk ada vektor-vektor ini dan nombor-nombor ini bila kita bekerja dengan
matriks unitary U yang tertentu, dan ia juga boleh jadi sangat
berguna cuma untuk tahu
bahawa ungkapan sedemikian sentiasa mungkin sebagai cara untuk membuktikan perkara tertentu tentang matriks unitary misalnya.
Dalam pernyataan teorem ini, setiap nombor ini,
Lambda satu hingga lambda N, ditulis dengan cara tertentu
sebagai E kepada kuasa dua pi I kali theta di mana setiap theta
theta satu hingga theta N adalah nombor nyata, dan
kita akan kembali kepada cara
penulisan setiap nombor ini
dalam seketika lagi.
Perkara penting yang perlu diperhatikan
tentang vektor-vektor dan nombor-nombor ini ialah setiap vektor psi
K mestilah eigenvector matriks U dengan
eigenvalue lambda K yang sepadan.
Yang bermaksud kalau kita
darab psi K dengan U, apa yang kita dapat ialah lambda K kali psi K.
Jadi apa yang U buat kepada setiap vektor ini adalah cuma darabnya dengan nombor lambda K yang sepadan.
Secara umum untuk sesetengah vektor arbitrari, begini bukan cara U berfungsi, tapi eigenvector adalah istimewa.
Dan apa yang teorem beritahu kita ialah memang ada
asas orto normal daripada eigenvector-eigenvector ini.
Persamaan di bawah ni by the way, ikut dari ungkapan yang kita ada untuk U dari teorem, bersama-sama dengan fakta bahawa
vektor-vektor adalah ortonormal.
WEBVTT
Kalau kamu darab
ungkapan U kepada mana-mana psi K dan guna ortonormaliti vektor-vektor, kamu akan dapat jumlah di mana
semua suku adalah sifar
kecuali satu daripadanya, dan satu suku yang kita
tinggal ni nampak macam ni.
Sekarang kita boleh definisikan masalah
anggaran fasa.
Masalah ni agak
lain sikit macam yang akan kita tengok.
Kita diberi dua perkara. Pertama, kita diberi penerangan quantum circuit unitary,
yang bertindak ke atas N qubit
untuk sesetengah pilihan N, dan bila kita kata circuit ini
adalah unitary,
kita cuma maksudkan bahawa semua
gate adalah unitary, jadi tiada pengukuran
dalam circuit ini.
Kedua, kita diberi keadaan N qubit psi, dan itulah bahagian yang lain sikit.
Kita sebenarnya ada input
keadaan kuantum untuk masalah ini, dan ia adalah satu salinan keadaan ini.
Untuk semua masalah pengiraan lain yang kita bincangkan dalam siri ini, inputnya adalah klasik, sama ada dalam bentuk rentetan
bit atau sebagai kotak hitam.
Dan itu tak menghairankan sebab masalah pengiraan
yang kita temui dalam kehidupan seharian kita cenderung jadi klasik,
sebab itulah masalah yang
paling kita ambil berat.
Cara kamu boleh
fikirkan masalah ini ialah ia adalah sesuatu yang muncul atau berkemungkinan muncul sebagai sub masalah.
Dan prosedur anggaran fasa yang akhirnya akan kita hasilkan adalah sesuatu yang
kita gunakan secara amnya sebagai sub-rutin
dalam pengiraan yang lebih besar, mungkin satu untuk masalah klasik
yang kita ambil berat.
Sekarang, ini akan jadi masalah janji dan keadaan psi bukan
sebarang keadaan kuantum biasa.
Kita dijanjikan bahawa psi adalah eigenvector bagi operasi unitary U yang mana-mana yang circuit yang diberi huraikan.
Dan matlamatnya adalah untuk cari atau
menganggarkan eigenvalue yang sepadan dengan eigenvector psi.
Jom nyatakan masalah ni
dengan lebih tepat sikit.
Input terdiri daripada quantum circuit
unitary ke atas N qubit, yang boleh dikodkan sebagai rentetan bit
menggunakan kaedah mana-mana yang kita suka untuk mengkodkan penerangan quantum circuit, bersama-sama dengan keadaan N qubit psi.
Kita boleh panggil circuit tu apa saja yang kita mahu, tapi apa yang penting dari segi pernyataan masalah ini adalah operasi unitary itu sendiri
yang dilakukan bila circuit dijalankan, dan operasi unitary itu
dihuraikan oleh Matriks U.
Tapi kita tak diberi U sebagai matriks, kita cuma diberi penerangan quantum circuit yang melaksanakan U.
Janjinya, macam yang dah saya nyatakan, ialah psi adalah eigenvector U.
Jadi kalau kita jalankan circuit kita ke atas psi, kita akan dapat psi keluar didarab dengan eigenvalue berapa pun,
yang akan jadi fasa global
dalam situasi itu.
Dan akhirnya, output masalah adalah anggaran eigenvalue yang sepadan dengan psi, dan khususnya kita mencari
anggaran nombor nyata theta, antara sifar dan satu, termasuk
sifar, tapi tidak termasuk satu
yang memenuhi persamaan
yang ada pada skrin.
Untuk terangkan cara
parameteran eigenvalue yang sepadan dengan pis ini, dan juga untuk jelaskan apa yang kita maksudkan dengan anggaran,
jom lukis gambar
bulatan unit kompleks.
Kita boleh letak nombor satu, I,
negatif satu, dan negatif I di tempat biasa mereka dan kita boleh pertimbangkan
sesetengah titik arbitrari pada
bulatan yang diparameterkan oleh theta macam yang ada dalam pernyataan masalah.
Ini adalah titik yang kita
dapat kalau kita mula dari satu dan putar dengan sudut
dua kali pi kali theta, jadi sudutnya bukan
theta, ia adalah dua pi theta,
dan cara lain untuk fikirkan tentangnya ialah kalau kita mula dari satu dan kita perjalanan jarak dua pi theta pada bulatan itu sendiri,
kita akan sampai ke titik kita, E kepada
dua kali pi kali theta.
Setiap titik dalam bulatan unit kompleks boleh diwakili dengan cara ini
untuk pilihan theta yang unik.
Dan itu sebab kita pergi
sekeliling bulatan bila theta pergi dari sifar ke satu, dan kalau kita pergi semua
jalan ke theta sama dengan satu,
kita akan kembali ke mana
kita mula di theta sama dengan sifar, jadi itulah sebab kita masukkan sifar, tapi kita tak masukkan satu.
Cuma untuk pastikan bahawa setiap
titik pada bulatan unit kompleks sepadan dengan nilai unik theta dalam julat yang kita pertimbangkan.
Ada pelbagai cara
yang boleh kita bayangkan untuk menganggarkan nilai tertentu theta, tapi cara yang kita akan buat ialah menganggarkan theta dengan pecahan,
di mana penyebutnya
adalah dua kepada kuasa M untuk sesetengah pilihan integer positif M, dan pengangkanya adalah integer y
antara sifar dan dua kepada M tolak satu.
Kamu boleh fikirkan ini sebagai anggaran M bit kepada theta kalau kamu nak, dan kita boleh tulis nombor ini dalam notasi perduaan
di mana kita ada titik perduaan diikuti dengan perwakilan perduaan
Y.
Saya cakap titik perduaan by the way
bukan titik perpuluhan sebab perpuluhan bermaksud asas 10 dan saya bercakap tentang asas dua
di sini, tapi ideanya sama.
Tapi dalam mana-mana kes kita boleh
fikirkannya cuma sebagai pecahan macam yang
ada pada skrin.
Dan untuk jelaskan, bila kita fikirkan tentang
anggaran dalam konteks ini, harus difahami
bahawa nilai-nilai theta
WEBVTT
yang hampir sifar dan nilai-nilai theta yang hampir satu sebenarnya berdekatan antara satu sama lain.
Jadi contohnya, kalau theta sama dengan 0.99 dan kita menganggarkan nilai
theta ini dengan nilai sifar,
maka itu adalah anggaran yang agak bagus dalam erti kata ia adalah
dalam satu per seratus nilai sebenar, bila
kita pusing balik keliling bulatan
dan balik ke sifar bila kita sampai ke satu.
Istilah modular satu kadang-kadang digunakan untuk menghuraikan situasi, di mana kita pada asasnya
menyamakan theta sama dengan satu dengan theta sama dengan sifar.
Perkara penting ialah kita betul-betul ambil berat tentang lokasi titik
E kepada dua pi I theta pada bulatan unit,
dan memikirkan tentang
cara menganggarkan theta ini masuk akal bila kita ada tujuan itu dalam fikiran.
Pernyataan masalah itu sendiri,
macam yang ada pada skrin, tak spesifik tentang seberapa bagus anggaran kepada theta perlu jadi,
tapi itu adalah sesuatu yang kita boleh laraskan bergantung kepada keperluan kita.
Dalam sesetengah situasi kita mungkin berpuas hati dengan anggaran ketepatan rendah
kepada theta, dan dalam situasi lain kita mungkin memerlukan
anggaran ketepatan sangat tinggi, dan pernyataan masalah itu sendiri
boleh diperhalus dengan sewajarnya.
Seterusnya kita akan tengok macam mana kita boleh selesaikan
masalah anggaran fasa dengan komputer kuantum dan
kita akan mulakan dengan pemanasan.
Ini tak akan jadi penyelesaian akhir
kita kepada masalah.
Apa yang akan kita buat ialah guna fenomena phase kickback untuk cuba pelajari sesuatu
tentang eigenvalue yang sepadan dengan eigenvector yang diberi.
Ingat bahawa dalam
masalah anggaran fasa kita diberi penerangan
quantum circuit unitary untuk sesetengah operasi U,
dan apa yang kita buat pertama ialah
guna penerangan circuit ini untuk cipta circuit baru yang melaksanakan operasi controlled U macam
yang digambarkan pada skrin.
Ini agak mudah untuk dilakukan. Apa yang boleh kita buat ialah tambah control qubit, yang digambarkan pada
bahagian atas dalam diagram ini
dan guna control qubit baru ini
sebagai kawalan untuk setiap gate tunggal yang
ada dalam circuit kita.
Jadi semua gate diterapkan kalau control qubit ini ditetapkan ke satu, dan tiada satu pun diterapkan kalau control qubit ditetapkan ke sifar,
Itu bermakna kita akan
perlukan versi controlled bagi setiap gate yang
ada dalam circuit U, tapi kita tak perlu fikirkan tentang gate controlled baru ini
sebagai gate tunggal kalau kita tak mahu. Ia boleh dilaksanakan
sebagai circuit kecil yang dibuat daripada gate dari mana-mana set gate
yang kita pilih untuk guna. Dan bila kita dah ada versi
controlled U, kita boleh pertimbangkan untuk jalankan circuit ini,
di mana kita mula-mula letak control qubit ke dalam superposisi sifar dan satu, terapkan controlled U gate kepada eigenvector yang kita diberi,
kemudian terapkan Hadamard gate
kepada kawalan dan ukur.
Kita akan tengok kenapa masuk akal untuk buat ni bila kita pergi melalui analisis, tapi walaupun sebelum kita sampai ke butiran, kita boleh terus nampak persamaan
dengan algoritma Deutsche misalnya, di mana kita menerapkan
beberapa Hadamard gate dan mengukur sebagai cara
untuk menyelidiki dengan berkesan
apa yang sesetengah operasi yang diberi
sedang buat di sini.
Ia adalah unitary yang dikawalselia
bukannya query gate, tapi ada idea-idea yang sangat serupa sedang dimainkan.
Jadi jom tengok apa yang circuit buat.
Keadaan awal adalah eigenvector psi, di-tensor dengan keadaan sifar
untuk control qubit,
menerapkan Hadamard gate pertama mengubah keadaan
qubit atas kepada keadaan plus dan kita boleh kembangkan keseluruhan
keadaan seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini.
Kita kemudian terapkan operasi controlled U dan apa yang dilakukan ialah menerapkan U kepada psi bila control qubit ditetapkan ke satu,
tapi tidak bila ia ditetapkan ke sifar. Jadi kita dapat keadaan pi dua
yang ditulis pada skrin.
Kita boleh permudahkan keadaan
menggunakan fakta bahawa psi adalah eigenvector U dengan eigenvalue e kepada dua pi I theta.
Jadi kita dapat eigenvalue itu didarab suku kedua, tapi bukan yang pertama.
Dan kita boleh permudahkan menggunakan kebilinearan
darab tensor.
Jadi apa yang kita ada di sini adalah fenomena phase kickback, tapi kali ni ia berlaku untuk sesetengah eigenvector psi arbitrari bagi sesetengah operasi unitary U arbitrari,
berbanding operasi not yang diterapkan kepada keadaan minus lebih khususnya.
Jadi itulah keadaan selepas operasi controlled U diterapkan.
By the way, patut
ambil sebentar untuk perhatikan bahawa keadaan bawah N qubit masih lagi eigenvector psi.
Yang bagus sebab itu
memberi kita peluang untuk gunakannya lagi kalau kita pilih.
Kemudian Hadamard gate kedua dilaksanakan dan inilah keadaan yang kita dapat.
Dan saya tak tunjukkan semua
butiran derivasi di sini, tapi kalau kamu terapkan
Hadamard gate dan permudahkan, ini yang patut kamu dapat.
Jadi itulah keadaan tepat
sebelum pengukuran.
Jadi kita boleh fokus pada keadaan ini untuk tengok apa yang boleh kita pelajari
tentang theta dengan mengukur.
Dan kalau kita ukur qubit atas
atau qubit paling kanan, inilah kebarangkalian yang kita dapat untuk dua hasil.
Dan di sini telah guna
beberapa formula asas yang menghubungkan sin dan kosinus
kepada eksponen kompleks untuk nyatakan kebarangkalian ini
dari segi sin dan kosinus.
Khususnya, kebarangkalian untuk mendapat sifar adalah kosinus kuasa dua pi kali theta dan kebarangkalian untuk mendapat satu
WEBVTT
adalah sin kuasa dua sudut yang sama. Dan ini masuk akal
sebab sin kuasa dua tambah kosinus kuasa dua
mana-mana sudut adalah sama dengan satu.
Jadi kebarangkalian kita
berjumlah satu macam yang kita jangkakan.
Dan inilah plot kebarangkalian ini sebagai fungsi theta.
Untuk jelaskan, ini adalah plot
kebarangkalian itu sendiri berbanding plot yang menggambarkan taburan kebarangkalian tunggal misalnya.
Contohnya, kalau theta
sama dengan setengah, maka kebarangkalian yang
kita dapat hasil satu yang dilukis dalam ungu adalah sama dengan satu
manakala kebarangkalian
untuk mendapat hasil sifar, yang dilukis dalam biru, adalah sifar.
Sebaliknya, kalau theta sama dengan satu
suku atau tiga suku, maka kita ada bahawa setiap dua hasil adalah sama kemungkinannya.
Dan sudah tentunya untuk semua pilihan theta, jumlah kebarangkalian adalah sama dengan satu macam yang dah kita perhatikan.
Jadi kita tak tahu dengan tepat apa
theta dari prosedur ini, tapi ia memberi kita beberapa
maklumat tentang theta.
Dan kalau kita bayangkan situasi di mana kita dijanjikan
bahawa theta sama dengan sifar atau theta sama dengan setengah, prosedur ini akan beritahu kita
tepat yang mana satu daripada
dua kemungkinan itu.
Jadi itulah cara mudah kita boleh guna fenomena phase kickback untuk pelajari sesuatu tentang eigenvalue.
Jadi macam mana kita boleh pelajari lebih
tentang eigenvalue?
Nah, ini adalah situasi di mana kita boleh biarkan
kejahilan menjadi panduan kita.
Sebab memang tak banyak
perkara yang boleh kita buat.
Kita tak tahu banyak perkara
tentang eigenvector sin, dan kita juga tak tahu
banyak tentang operasi U.
Kita ada circuit untuk U, tapi bagi kita ia adalah
kekacauan yang mengerikan dan mengelirukan yang kita tak akan dapat buat
apa-apa erti dengan memeriksa.
Tapi satu pilihan semula jadi ialah jalankan circuit beberapa kali.
Khususnya, kita boleh cuba buat tepat perkara yang sama yang baru kita buat, kecuali bahawa bukannya menerapkan cuma satu operasi controlled U,
kita terapkan operasi itu dua kali. Atau kita boleh terapkannya berapa kali saja, tapi jom mulakan dengan dua kali
cuma untuk tengok apa yang berlaku.
Nah, apa yang berlaku tu sebenarnya agak
mudah. Dengan menerapkan operasi controlled
U dua kali, kita pada asasnya cuma
mengkuasakan dua eigenvalue
sebab ia akan dihalauan ke dalam
fasa qubit atas dua kali bukannya cuma sekali.
Dan jadi bila kita fikirkan tentang
kebarangkalian hasil sebagai fungsi theta, kita pada asasnya cuma
menggandakan frekuensi.
Untuk setiap pilihan theta yang mungkin, kebarangkalian hasil
adalah sama seperti yang ada kalau kita gandakan theta dan kemudian
ambil bahagian pecahan
untuk mendapat nombor antara sifar dan satu.
Contohnya, kalau theta
sama dengan setengah, maka eigenvalue adalah negatif satu.
Jadi dengan menerapkan U dua kali kita pada asasnya mengkuasakan dua eigenvalue dan hasilnya adalah sama seperti yang ada untuk theta sama dengan sifar.
Iaitu kebarangkalian
untuk hasil sifar, yang digambarkan dalam biru, adalah sama dengan satu, dan kebarangkalian untuk hasil satu, yang digambarkan dalam ungu, adalah sama dengan sifar.
Ini sangat mudah, tapi kita sebenarnya boleh dapat
beberapa maklumat tambahan tentang theta dengan buat ni.
Contohnya, kalau kita tahu terlebih dahulu bahawa sama ada theta sama dengan sifar atau theta sama dengan satu suku, maka circuit ini akan dedahkan kepada kita
yang mana satu daripada dua kemungkinan itu.
Sebaliknya, kita dah tidak boleh bezakan kes bahawa theta sama dengan sifar dari kes bahawa theta sama dengan setengah.
Jadi prosedur ini tak lebih bagus dari yang sebelum ni bila
kita ada satu controlled U gate tapi dengan juga menjalankan circuit ini
kita boleh dapat maklumat tambahan.
Tak jelas segera
macam mana maklumat tambahan yang boleh kita dapat dengan mengulang operasi controlled U beberapa kali
boleh diselaraskan dengan
maklumat yang kita dapat dengan melaksanakannya cuma sekali, dan sebenarnya ada beberapa
cara yang boleh kita teruskan.
Misalnya, ada teknik yang dipanggil anggaran fasa berulang, yang melibatkan menjalankan circuit macam yang dah kita lihat,
bersama-sama dengan beberapa variasi kecil padanya, untuk hasilkan anggaran kepada theta.
Tapi saya akan huraikan
apa yang boleh dipanggil pendekatan lebih tradisional, di mana kita guna satu quantum circuit yang ada berbilang control qubit
yang mengawal bilangan
iterasi berbeza operasi unitary U.
Pertama saya akan huraikan macam mana ini
berfungsi untuk dua control qubit dan kemudian seketika lagi kita akan perluas ke lebih daripada dua control qubit.
Inilah quantum circuit
yang menggunakan dua control qubit.
Control qubit atas
mengawal satu operasi U manakala qubit kedua dari atas
mengawal dua salinan U.
Jadi apa yang kita buat ialah menggabungkan dua circuit yang kita lihat sebelum ni, dengan cara yang memanfaatkan salinan tunggal
eigenvector psi yang kita ada.
Kamu akan perhatikan bagaimanapun
bahawa Hadamard gate selepas operasi controlled U
telah dibuang dan belum ada pengukuran lagi.
Apa yang kita akan buat ialah
tengok macam mana circuit ini berfungsi dan kemudian kita akan cari tahu
apa yang patut kita buat dengan dua qubit atas
untuk pelajari sebanyak mungkin tentang nilai theta yang
kita cuba anggaran.
Selepas Hadamard gate dilaksanakan, kita ada keadaan yang
ditunjukkan pada skrin.
WEBVTT
Dan ini akan jadi cara penulisan keadaan yang mudah untuk
tengok apa yang berlaku seterusnya.
A sifar dan A satu adalah bit, dan kalau kita fikirkan tentang dua qubit atas sebagai register dua qubit,
kita sedang fikirkan tentang A sifar, yang sepadan dengan qubit atas sebagai bit kurang bererti, dan A satu yang sepadan
dengan control qubit bawah
sebagai bit lebih bererti.
Selepas operasi controlled U
pertama dilaksanakan, kita dapat keadaan ini.
Keadaan klasik yang sepadan dengan control qubit atas adalah a sifar, jadi hasil phase kickback
boleh dinyatakan dengan cara ini. Kemudian selepas operasi controlled U kedua dan
ketiga
dilaksanakan, kita dapat keadaan ini.
Ideanya sama seperti yang pertama, kecuali kali ni kita menerapkan operasi controlled U dua kali.
Jadi kita darab A satu dengan dua dalam
eksponen untuk mencerminkan ini.
Dan sekarang kita boleh permudahkan ungkapan ini dengan memikirkan tentang bit
A satu dan A sifar bersama-sama sebagai integer antara sifar dan
tiga menggunakan notasi perduaan.
Iaitu bila kita fikirkan tentang
rentetan dua bit, A satu A sifar, sebagai pengekodan perduaan
integer,
apa yang kita dapat ialah dua
kali A satu tambah A sifar.
Dan kefahamannya ialah
bila kita tulis Cat X, kita bercakap tentang X yang ditulis sebagai rentetan perduaan dengan panjang
dua menggunakan notasi perduaan.
Jadi sekarang jom fokus pada
dua control qubit ini untuk cari tahu apa yang
kita boleh pelajari tentang theta daripadanya pada ketika ini.
Baki N qubit masih
dalam keadaan psi yang sama yang asalnya kita diberi, yang merupakan benda yang sungguh luar biasa tentang pendekatan ini
sebab macam yang saya cakap sebelum ni, kita boleh guna keadaan itu lagi kalau kita nak dapat lebih banyak
maklumat tentang theta.
Tapi buat masa ni, jom cuma fikirkan tentang apa yang boleh kita pelajari dari
dua control qubit ini.
Untuk bantu kita cari tahu macam mana nak teruskan, jom bayangkan kita dijanjikan bahawa theta sama dengan Y dibahagi empat
untuk sesetengah integer y antara sifar dan tiga.
Secara umum, theta mungkin bukan
salah satu daripada empat nilai ini, tapi ini adalah kes semula jadi untuk dipertimbangkan.
Kita nampak dalam versi control qubit tunggal asal prosedur itu bahawa kalau kita dijanjikan theta sama ada sifar atau setengah
circuit itu akan dedahkan yang mana satunya. Dan kita juga perhatikan bahawa dalam versi di mana kita menerapkan
operasi controlled U dua kali,
kita boleh bezakan dengan sempurna kes bahawa theta sama dengan sifar dari kes bahawa theta
sama dengan satu suku.
Jadi kita mungkin berharap bahawa dengan circuit baru kita kita boleh bezakan empat kes ini.
Pada asasnya, apa yang
kita buat ialah kita menggunakan gagasan masalah janji
untuk jadikan masalah lebih mudah, supaya kita boleh tengok macam mana nak teruskan.
Dan itu bukan idea yang buruk, secara amnya. Kalau kamu ada masalah dan kamu
tak tahu macam mana nak selesaikannya, cuba jadikannya lebih mudah.
Kalau kamu boleh selesaikan masalah yang lebih mudah, pandangan yang kamu dapat mungkin berguna dalam menyelesaikan masalah yang lebih umum.
Dan kalau kamu tak boleh selesaikan masalah yang lebih mudah, kamu mungkin belum bersedia
untuk masalah yang lebih umum.
Jadi terus jadikannya lebih mudah
sehingga kamu boleh selesaikannya.
Pun begitu, kembali kepada masalah kita, jom definisikan keadaan dua qubit untuk setiap nilai Y yang mungkin.
Dalam erti kata lain, phi Y sama dengan keadaan
yang ditunjukkan pada bahagian atas skrin bila theta dipilih
khusus untuk jadi Y dibahagi empat.
Dan inilah empat
keadaan itu yang ditulis dengan jelas.
Jadi cuma untuk ulang, kalau
theta sama dengan Y dibahagi empat untuk Y ialah sifar, satu, dua, atau
tiga dan kita jalankan circuit kita,
kita akan tertinggal dengan
salah satu daripada empat keadaan ini, mana yang sepadan
dengan nilai Y yang betul.
Dan kita cuma nak cari tahu
yang mana satunya.
Dan soalannya ialah, adakah ini mungkin?
Dan jawapan kepada soalan itu adalah ya, sebab empat keadaan ini adalah ortogon.
Kalau kamu kira hasil darab dalaman
antara mana-mana pasangan, kamu akan dapat sifar.
Dan sebab ia ortogon, ia boleh dibezakan dengan sempurna oleh pengukuran projektif.
Dan khususnya kita boleh
nyatakan pengukuran sedemikian dengan mendefinisikan satu unjuran untuk setiap vektor macam yang ada di sini.
Ini sentiasa berfungsi, bila-bila masa
kita ada asas ortonormal, dan kamu boleh semak ini
berbanding definisi yang kita lihat dalam pelajaran tiga
untuk kes spesifik ini
kalau kamu nak. Jadi kita simpulkan bahawa memang
mungkin untuk capai tugas kita,
iaitu untuk ketahui nilai Y dari keadaan yang ditunjukkan
pada bahagian atas skrin.
Dan kalau kita nak buat tu
dengan quantum circuit, kita boleh teruskan macam yang akan saya jelaskan sekarang.
Pertama kita boleh definisikan matriks unitary V yang lajurnya adalah empat
vektor yang disenaraikan mengikut tertib.
Matriks itu akan ada tindakan yang dihuraikan pada bahagian bawah skrin,
pada keadaan asas standard,
dan kita boleh tulis matriks
untuk tengok macam mana rupanya.
Sebab V memetakan setiap keadaan asas standard, kappa Y kepada vektor phi Y, kita ada bahawa dengan menerapkan V dagger,
atau dalam erti kata lain V songsang kepada phi Y akan mengubah balik cara lain kepada keadaan asas standard yang sepadan.
WEBVTT
Jadi apa yang kita boleh buat ialah terapkan V dagger kepada apa saja keadaan yang kita
dapat dari circuit kita.
Dan kemudian kalau kita lakukan
pengukuran asas standard, kita akan dapat nombor Y
yang kita cari, dinyatakan sebagai rentetan
panjang dua dalam perduaan.
Sebelum kita teruskan, jom bincang sikit lagi
tentang matriks unitary V.
Ini adalah matriks istimewa dan
kamu mungkin pernah jumpa sebelum ni.
Ia adalah matriks yang berkaitan
dengan operasi linear ke atas vektor empat dimensi yang dikenali sebagai transformasi Fourier diskrit.
Untuk lebih tepat, transformasi Fourier diskrit boleh didefinisikan untuk mana-mana
dimensi integer positif, dan kita akan tengok
ia secara umum dalam seketika.
Dan inilah rupanya
khusus bila dimensi sama dengan empat.
Kita boleh fikirkan tentang
transformasi Fourier diskrit dengan cara yang berbeza.
Kita boleh fikirkannya secara abstrak murni sebagai pemetaan linear ke atas vektor yang boleh diwakili oleh matriks.
Dan kita juga boleh fikirkan tentang
ia sebagai masalah pengiraan di mana kita diberi vektor, dan kita nak kira hasilnya
dengan menerapkan pemetaan linear ini.
Itu rupanya jadi masalah pengiraan yang sungguh penting,
dan ada algoritma yang sangat cekap untuk melaksanakan pengiraan itu
yang dikenali sebagai transformasi Fourier cepat.
Sebenarnya, ini adalah masalah yang begitu penting dalam pemprosesan isyarat misalnya, sehingga transformasi Fourier
cepat dianggap oleh ramai
sebagai salah satu algoritma yang paling penting dan berpengaruh
yang pernah ditemui.
Kita juga boleh fikirkan tentang
transformasi Fourier diskrit sebagai operasi kuantum unitary yang boleh diterapkan kepada
vektor keadaan kuantum.
Dan bila kita fikirkannya dengan cara itu, kita panggilnya Transformasi Fourier Kuantum,
atau QFT untuk singkat.
Dari segi matematik, ia pada asasnya benda yang sama seperti transformasi Fourier diskrit, tapi kita panggilnya transformasi Fourier kuantum
cuma untuk jelaskan bahawa ia adalah operasi yang diterapkan kepada vektor keadaan kuantum.
Jadi jom tukar nama matriks kita, dari V kepada QFT empat untuk mencerminkan fakta
bahawa operasi yang kita hasilkan sebenarnya adalah Transformasi Fourier Kuantum.
Jadi inilah circuit lengkap untuk mengetahui nilai Y bila kita dijanjikan bahawa
theta sama dengan Y dibahagi empat
untuk Y ialah sifar, satu, dua, atau tiga.
Dan cuma untuk pastikan ia jelas, kita menerapkan songsang
transformasi Fourier kuantum, atau dalam erti kata lain QFT empat dagger
untuk memetakan salah satu daripada empat keadaan yang mungkin kembali kepada keadaan asas standard, cat Y, supaya kita boleh pulihkan Y dengan mengukur.
Jadi itulah circuit yang kita
dapat dari memikirkan tentang versi yang dijanjikan
masalah anggaran fasa, di mana kita dijanjikan bahawa theta
adalah sifar, satu suku, setengah,
atau tiga suku, tapi tak ada apa yang menghalang kita
dari menjalankan circuit ini untuk
nilai theta yang arbitrari.
Dan kalau kita buat tu, inilah
kebarangkalian untuk empat hasil yang mungkin
yang kita dapat.
Setiap daripada empat nilai
yang mungkin untuk Y ada warnanya sendiri, dan plot memberitahu kita
apa kebarangkalian untuk setiap satu sebagai fungsi theta.
Jadi misalnya, kalau theta
sama dengan tiga suku, kita akan dapat hasil
tiga dengan kebarangkalian satu,
nah kebarangkalian untuk tiga hasil lain adalah semua sifar macam yang dah kita tahu dari memikirkan tentang versi yang dijanjikan masalah.
Kalau theta hampir kepada tiga suku tapi bukan tepat tiga suku, akan ada kebarangkalian bukan sifar yang berkaitan dengan hasil lain,
tapi kita masih akan dapat hasil
tiga dengan kebarangkalian tinggi.
Jadi walaupun theta mungkin
tidak sama dengan Y dibahagi empat, kita masih boleh fikirkan tentang hasil yang kita dapat dari pengukuran dibahagi dengan empat
sebagai teka-teki atau
anggaran untuk theta.
Tekaan mungkin salah, tapi ia tetap
memberi kita maklumat.
Dan satu perkara yang
kita boleh pelajari dari plot ialah anggaran terbaik sentiasa mempunyai
kebarangkalian tertinggi yang berkaitan dengannya.
Bila saya cakap anggaran terbaik, saya maksudkan nilai Y dibahagi empat yang paling hampir kepada nilai theta sebenar,
dalam erti modular satu. Kes paling teruk yang mungkin ialah theta adalah tepat di tengah-tengah antara
dua nilai Y dibahagi empat.
Contohnya, kalau theta sama
dengan tiga per lapan atau 0.375, dalam kes ini kita nampak
bahawa anggaran-anggaran
satu suku dan dua suku
atau setengah adalah sama baiknya.
Jadi dalam kes tertentu
ini sebenarnya ada dua anggaran terbaik bukannya satu.
Dan kita sama kemungkinannya untuk mendapat hasil satu
dan hasil dua.
Dua hasil lain sifar dan tiga, yang tak memberikan anggaran yang sangat bagus
kepada theta bila kita bahagi dengan empat, sebenarnya muncul dengan beberapa kebarangkalian
yang nampaknya cuma
bawah 10% dalam kedua-dua kes.
Jadi prosedur ini tak sempurna, tapi ia memberi kita maklumat.
Dan patut diperhatikan bahawa
tanpa mengira theta, kita sentiasa dijamin untuk mendapat sama ada anggaran terbaik
atau salah satu daripada dua anggaran terbaik bila ada seri, dengan kebarangkalian yang
nampaknya cuma di atas 40%.
WEBVTT
Dan semakin hampir theta
kepada anggaran, semakin tinggi kebarangkalian untuk nampak nilai Y yang sepadan.
Dan itu adalah peningkatan yang agak
ketara berbanding menggunakan satu control qubit.
Ini sebenarnya adalah prosedur
anggaran fasa bila kita pilih untuk guna dua control qubit.
Dan apa yang kita akan buat seterusnya ialah perluas prosedur ini
secara semula jadi, di mana kita tak berhenti dengan
cuma dua control qubit
tapi kita guna berapa banyak
control qubit yang kita pilih.
Dan apa yang kita akan nampak ialah dengan
memperluaskan prosedur, dengan menambah lebih banyak control qubit, kita akan dapat lebih dan lebih banyak
anggaran theta yang tepat. Dan itulah yang akan jadi prosedur
anggaran fasa umum.
Untuk memperluaskan prosedur
anggaran fasa dari dua control qubit
kepada berapa banyak yang kita pilih, kita perlu faham
macam mana transformasi Fourier kuantum didefinisikan untuk dimensi lain.
Dan kita juga kena bincang macam mana ia boleh dilaksanakan
dengan quantum circuit.
Inilah definisi
transformasi Fourier kuantum bila dimensi adalah
integer positif arbitrari N.
Di sini kita sedang fikirkan tentang operasi ini sebagai operasi ke atas sistem yang keadaan klasiknya adalah
sifar hingga N tolak satu.
Dan di sini matriks yang
menghuraikan operasi ini telah dinyatakan menggunakan
notasi langsung.
Kita juga boleh huraikannya dari segi tindakannya
pada keadaan asas standard, cuma untuk hubungkannya dengan
apa yang dah kita lihat bila N sama dengan empat.
Jadi inilah rupanya
bila N sama dengan satu, yang bukan kes yang sangat menarik.
Inilah untuk N sama dengan dua, dan kamu akan perhatikan apa yang kita dapat dalam kes ini adalah operasi Hadamard.
Inilah transformasi Fourier
kuantum untuk N sama dengan tiga.
Untuk N sama dengan empat, yang
dah kita lihat sebelum ni.
Dan untuk satu contoh terakhir, inilah bila N sama dengan lapan.
Macam yang kita ada sebelum ni
untuk kes N sama dengan empat, Inilah matriks yang kita kaitkan dengan transformasi Fourier diskrit
untuk setiap dimensi. Tapi kita panggilnya
transformasi Fourier kuantum bila kita nak fikirkan tentang
ia sebagai operasi kuantum.
Kadang-kadang by the way, faktor utama satu per punca kuasa dua N tak dimasukkan bila kita fikirkan tentang transformasi Fourier diskrit sebagai matriks,
tapi kita perlukan faktor itu di sini untuk pastikan kita dapat matriks unitary.
Ada juga kadang-kadang tanda tolak dalam setiap eksponen, tapi tak selalu.
Ia pada asasnya cuma pilihan peribadi yang tak mengubah sifat asas
transformasi.
Tapi dalam mana-mana kes, kita akan definisikan transformasi Fourier kuantum macam yang ditulis di sini pada skrin.
Ada notasi singkatan yang sangat berguna
yang biasa dan kita akan gunakannya
sedikit lagi dalam pelajaran.
Dan itu ialah mendefinisikan
nombor kompleks omega N, macam yang kita ada di sini.
Khususnya sebagai e kepada dua pi I dibahagi N, yang juga boleh ditulis
menggunakan sin dan kosinus
macam yang kita ada di sini. Kadang-kadang kita panggil nombor ini
punca ke-N kesatuan sebab bila kita naikkannya
kepada kuasa N, kita dapat satu.
Inilah gambar yang menunjukkan beberapa contoh.
Omega satu sama dengan satu, omega dua sama dengan negatif satu, dan omega empat sama dengan I.
Secara umum untuk mendapat omega N, kita boleh bayangkan memotong bulatan unit menjadi N bahagian yang sama saiz macam pizza yang dikongsi oleh N orang
dan omega N berada di
sudut bahagian pertama, dengan mengandaikan bahawa sudut lain
bahagian itu berada di satu.
Jadi khususnya bila N
bertambah besar dan besar, bahagian-bahagian akan jadi lebih kecil dan kecil, dan omega N akan
semakin hampir dan hampir kepada satu.
Dan sekarang kalau kita guna notasi itu kita boleh nyatakan
transformasi Fourier kuantum dengan cara yang lebih ringkas sikit.
Kadang-kadang notasi ini
membantu untuk kekalkan perkara mudah macam yang akan kita nampak berlaku
sedikit lagi dalam pelajaran.
Ada pelaksanaan quantum circuit
yang cekap untuk transformasi Fourier kuantum
bila N adalah kuasa dua,
yang kita akan lihat sekarang. Walaupun kita cenderung definisikan
transformasi Fourier kuantum untuk mana-mana dimensi N,
kita hanya akan memerlukannya
dalam kes bahawa N adalah kuasa dua, untuk memperluaskan
prosedur anggaran fasa.
Pelaksanaan itu akan
menggunakan controlled phase gate yang digambarkan macam yang
kita ada di sini pada skrin.
Ia kelihatan seperti dua
kawalan yang disambungkan bersama-sama berserta nombor yang
adalah alpha dalam kes ini.
Dan tindakan gate ini dihuraikan oleh matriks yang ditunjukkan di sini.
Ini secara harfiah adalah
controlled phase gate, bermakna kita ada control qubit yang mengawal phase gate.
Kita nampak phase gate jauh ke belakang dalam pelajaran satu.
Tapi untuk phase gate khusus, sebenarnya tak kira
qubit mana yang jadi kawalan dan yang mana jadi sasaran.
Dan kita nampak itu dalam pelajaran dua, untuk kes khusus Z gate.
Dan sekarang kita dah ada gagasan itu, kita boleh teruskan kepada macam mana
transformasi Fourier kuantum boleh dilaksanakan.
WEBVTT
Pelaksanaan ini bersifat rekursif dan mungkin cara paling mudah untuk
menghuraikannya dalam istilah mudah ialah dengan bagi contoh yang
boleh diperluas dengan mudah.
Inilah macam mana kita boleh buat
bila N sama dengan 32.
Jadi ada lima qubit.
Untuk jelaskan, kita sedang mengaitkan
keadaan asas standard lima qubit ini dengan integer antara sifar dan 31 menggunakan notasi perduaan.
Perkara pertama yang kita buat ialah laksanakan transformasi Fourier
kuantum untuk N sama dengan 16 kepada semua qubit kecuali
qubit paling kurang bererti,
yang berada di atas. Dan itulah bahagian
rekursif pembinaan.
Jadi untuk melaksanakan operasi ini, kita kena ikut corak yang sama tapi dengan satu qubit kurang.
Dan dalam kes asas kita
ada cuma satu qubit yang mana transformasi Fourier kuantum adalah cuma Hadamard gate.
Bila kita dah terapkan QFT ke atas semua qubit kecuali yang atas, kita terapkan beberapa controlled phase gate menggunakan fasa yang
ditunjukkan dalam diagram.
Kita kemudian terapkan Hadamard
gate kepada qubit atas, dan susun semula qubit sikit menggunakan beberapa swap gate.
Swap gate ini berkesan untuk memutarkan qubit secara siklik yang diperlukan untuk
pembinaan berfungsi.
Kita boleh ikut corak yang sama untuk pilihan N lain
asalkan ia adalah kuasa dua, di mana kita sentiasa mulakan controlled phase gate
dengan alpha adalah pi dibahagi
dua untuk qubit bawah dan bahagi dua setiap kali
bergerak ke kiri dalam diagram
untuk mendapat fasa berikutnya. Sekarang tak jelas langsung
bahawa pembinaan ini berfungsi.
Dan saya tak akan jelaskan
kenapa ia berfungsi dalam video ini.
Kalau kamu berminat untuk tengok
butiran kenapa ia berfungsi, kamu boleh jumpa dalam
kandungan bertulis untuk pelajaran.
Saya akan katakan bagaimanapun bahawa
apa yang dieksploitasi di sini adalah struktur asas
transformasi Fourier diskrit
dan sebenarnya ia adalah tepat
struktur yang sama yang membolehkan transformasi Fourier
cepat berfungsi.
Cara lain untuk cakap ini ialah kalau kita lihat transformasi Fourier cepat, kita boleh fikirkannya dari segi
quantum circuit.
Dan inilah circuit yang kita dapat.
Jadi berapa banyak gate yang kita perlukan secara keseluruhan untuk pelaksanaan ini?
Untuk cari tahu, jom biarkan SM menjadi bilangan gate yang
kita perlukan bila kita ada M qubit.
Bila M sama dengan satu, kita cuma perlukan satu gate sebab QFT adalah cuma operasi Hadamard dalam kes ini.
Kalau M sekurang-kurangnya dua, maka inilah
gate yang kita perlukan.
Pertama kita perlukan SM tolak satu gate untuk transformasi Fourier
kuantum ke atas M tolak satu qubit, berapa pun angkanya.
Kita juga perlukan M tolak satu
controlled phase gate, M tolak satu swap gate,
dan satu tambahan Hadamard gate.
Jadi inilah ungkapan
SM dalam kedua-dua kes bila M sama dengan satu dan
bila M sekurang-kurangnya dua.
Ini adalah contoh apa yang dipanggil hubungan rekurensi dan
ia muncul sangat kerap dalam analisis algoritma.
Yang ini
kebetulannya sangat mudah dan ia ada ungkapan bentuk tertutup yang dipanggil, yang boleh kita dapat dengan menjumlahkan.
Lebih tepat, nilai SM adalah jumlah M
integer ganjil berturutan pertama, yang sama dengan M kuasa dua,
macam yang mungkin pernah kamu temui sebelum ini atau mungkin kamu cuma perasan
pada suatu masa dalam hidup kamu.
Dan kebetulan agak mudah untuk buktikan formula ini benar secara induksi ke atas M kalau
kamu berminat dengan bukti formal.
Jadi itulah sahaja. Kita boleh laksanakan
transformasi Fourier kuantum ke atas M qubit menggunakan M kuasa dua gate.
Cuma beberapa
catatan tambahan yang sangat ringkas.
Pertama kita sebenarnya tak
perlukan semua swap gate yang saya huraikan.
Adalah mungkin untuk secara berkesan
menolak semuanya ke hujung asalkan kita laraskan qubit mana controlled phase gate
bertindak dengan sewajarnya.
Dan kalau kita buat tu kita hanya akan
perlukan M bahagi dua swap gate secara keseluruhan dengan membundarkan ke bawah.
Kita masih akan ada kos kuadratik, tapi bilangan gate boleh dikurangkan dengan cara ini pun begitu.
Dan satu catatan terakhir ialah kita sebenarnya boleh kurangkan kos lebih lagi kalau kita sanggup terima
anggaran yang agak bagus.
Contohnya, bila M bertambah besar, banyak controlled phase gate agak hampir kepada
operasi identiti,
dan menghapuskan yang
sangat hampir boleh jimatkan kita banyak gate sambil masih memberi kita
anggaran yang agak bagus.
Ia juga mungkin untuk menganggarkan transformasi Fourier kuantum
dengan circuit yang sangat cetek, bermakna yang ada kedalaman kecil, kalau itu adalah sesuatu
yang kita nak buat.
Dan sekarang kita tahu apa
transformasi Fourier kuantum untuk dimensi yang berbeza, serta macam mana ia boleh dilaksanakan bila dimensi adalah kuasa dua,
kita boleh kembali kepada
prosedur anggaran fasa dan tengok macam mana ia boleh diperluas di mana kita guna beberapa
bilangan M control qubit yang arbitrari.
Inilah rupanya prosedur sebagai quantum circuit untuk
pilihan M yang arbitrari.
Kita ada M control qubit di atas, yang kita andaikan semuanya
dimulakan kepada keadaan sifar.
Kita terapkan Hadamard
gate kepada setiap satu daripada mereka dan kemudian setiap satu daripada mereka digunakan sebagai control qubit untuk menerapkan beberapa kuasa
operasi unitary U,
WEBVTT
di mana kita gandakan bilangan
kali U diterapkan untuk setiap control qubit.
Di sini dalam diagram ini saya tunjukkan ini dengan memasukkan kuasa
pada U dalam kotak bukannya menunjukkan controlled U gate
diterapkan berkali-kali itu, sebagai cara untuk membuat
diagram lebih jelas dan jimat ruang supaya
ia muat pada skrin.
Sekarang perkara pertama yang perlu kita perhatikan
tentang prosedur ini ialah ia mungkin jadi sangat mahal.
Khususnya kita sedang
menggandakan bilangan kali setiap operasi U diterapkan
untuk setiap control qubit.
Dan kalau cara kita buat ni ialah cuma mengulang controlled U gate berapa kali yang kita perlukan,
kita akan dapat circuit yang besar. Ia akan jadi besar secara
eksponen dalam bilangan M.
Itu adalah had besar secara umum, dan khususnya ia menghadkan kemampuan kita untuk mendapat anggaran tepat
eigenvalue.
Dalam kes khusus pemfaktoran, yang kita akan sampai dalam sebentar, rupanya kita sangat bertuah dan kita boleh guna satu trick yang membolehkan kita
elak peningkatan eksponen dalam kos ini.
Tapi secara umum untuk operasi
unitary U yang arbitrari, ini tak akan mungkin dan
kita akan bayar harga yang tinggi
untuk meningkatkan
bilangan control qubit.
Saya tak akan
pergi melalui analisis terperinci circuit dalam video ini dan sebaliknya saya hanya akan sebut bahawa ada ungkapan yang agak mudah untuk keadaan
tepat sebelum pengukuran yang ditunjukkan di sini pada skrin.
Dari keadaan itu kita boleh dapat ungkapan untuk kebarangkalian
pelbagai hasil, dan ia rupanya macam ni.
Dan bila kita ada ungkapan ini,
kita boleh beralasan tentangnya, dan sebenarnya ungkapan ini
adalah semua yang kita perlukan untuk teruskan.
Macam yang saya cakap, saya tak akan masuk ke dalam
butiran dalam video ini, tapi kamu boleh jumpa ia dalam
kandungan bertulis untuk pelajaran dan rupanya ia sebenarnya tak begitu rumit,
jadi semak kalau kamu berminat. Kalau kita pergi melalui analisis, apa yang kita jumpa ialah situasinya
tak begitu berbeza
dari kes M sama dengan dua, kecuali bahawa kita dapat lebih ketepatan.
Khususnya, kita boleh fikirkan
pertama tentang kebarangkalian untuk mendapat yang paling baik atau salah satu daripada
dua anggaran terbaik,
yang boleh kita nyatakan macam yang ada di sini.
Kamu boleh abaikan subskrip satu pada nilai mutlak kalau kamu nak.
Ini cuma simbol yang
boleh kita guna untuk ingatkan diri kita bahawa kita sedang bercakap tentang
anggaran pada bulatan di mana kita fikirkan theta sama dengan sifar
dan theta sama dengan satu adalah benda yang sama. Perkara penting di sini ialah
kita sedang fikirkan tentang pilihan Y mana yang menjadikan Y dibahagi dua kepada kuasa M
sedekat mungkin kepada theta.
Dan sekali lagi, macam yang
kita ada untuk kes M sama dengan dua, kita dijamin untuk mendapat hasil Y ini dengan kebarangkalian sekurang-kurangnya 40%.
Sebenarnya, kebarangkalian adalah
sekurang-kurangnya empat dibahagi pi kuasa dua, yang sedikit lebih daripada 40%.
10 adalah anggaran yang tak teruk
untuk pi kuasa dua bila kamu tergesa-gesa.
Dan itu sebenarnya agak mengkagumkan. Apa yang kita bercakap tentang ialah mendapat anggaran paling baik kepada theta sebagai pecahan Y dibahagi dua kepada kuasa M
di mana Y adalah integer. Dan kita mendapat
anggaran paling baik dengan kebarangkalian lebih daripada 40%.
Kita juga boleh fikirkan tentang
anggaran yang lebih teruk.
Khususnya jom bayangkan
bahawa Y tak begitu bagus, dan lebih khusus lagi jom andaikan
bahawa ada anggaran yang lebih baik
kepada theta dalam bentuk yang sama yang terletak antara theta dan Y dibahagi dua kepada M,
yang boleh dinyatakan macam
yang ditulis pada skrin.
Dalam kes sedemikian
kebarangkalian untuk mendapat Y ini akan agak kecil, paling banyak 25%.
Ia sebenarnya akan lebih rendah daripada itu, tapi 25% adalah apa yang kita dapat dari
analisis yang agak mudah, tapi ia cukup bagus.
Sebagai contoh. Inilah plot yang kita dapat bila kita guna tiga control
qubit bukannya dua.
Kali ni saya hanya
plot kebarangkalian untuk hasil tiga, empat, dan lima sebab saya tak nak
rajah jadi terlalu berselerak.
Bila theta sama dengan
setengah misalnya, kita dijamin untuk mendapat hasil empat.
Dan jadi kita ambil
anggaran kita sebagai empat per lapan atau setengah sebab dua kepada
kuasa tiga adalah lapan.
Dan dalam kes ini kita tepat sekali. Dan selagi theta lebih hampir kepada setengah daripada ke tiga
per lapan misalnya,
kita mendapat hasil empat dengan kebarangkalian lebih tinggi
daripada hasil tiga.
Dan dengan kebarangkalian,
sekali lagi lebih besar daripada 40%.
Inilah plot bila M sama dengan empat. Dan kurvanya sebenarnya
kelihatan hampir sama, kecuali kita dah zum masuk
dengan faktor dua.
Jadi sekarang hasil yang diplot termasuk tujuh, lapan, dan sembilan dan kita mengambil anggaran sebagai salah satu nombor ini
dibahagi 16 bukannya lapan.
Dan saya akan tunjukkan satu lagi plot di mana kita naik ke M sama dengan lima.
Dan sekali lagi kita akan
zum masuk dengan faktor dua.
Dan inilah dia. Sekali lagi kurvanya kelihatan
hampir sama, tapi kita secara berkesan
menggandakan ketepatan kita.
WEBVTT
Dan macam sebelum ni kita mendapat anggaran paling baik kepada theta, dengan kebarangkalian lebih daripada 40%.
Itu cukup mengkagumkan. Tapi kalau 40% tak cukup bagus
sebagai ukuran keyakinan,
apa yang boleh kita buat ialah jalankan prosedur beberapa kali, dan
ambil mod hasilnya, bermaksud yang
paling kerap muncul.
Dan kalau kita buat tu, kita akan sangat berkemungkinan besar untuk dapat anggaran yang sangat bagus kepada theta.
Ingat by the way bahawa setiap kali kita jalankan
prosedur anggaran fasa kita ada eigenvector
yang keluar tidak berubah.
Jadi ia memang tersedia untuk kita jalankan prosedur
beberapa kali macam ni.
Pendeknya, kita sedang mengumpul
statistik tentang theta, dan perkaranya ialah dengan buat ni kita boleh dapat anggaran yang sangat tepat kepada theta
dengan keyakinan yang sangat tinggi, dan kita tak perlukan banyak iterasi prosedur untuk buat ni.
Dan itulah cara prosedur
anggaran fasa berfungsi.
Dalam bahagian terakhir pelajaran, kita akan terapkan teknik
anggaran fasa kepada masalah pemfaktoran integer.
Macam yang saya sebut di awal video, cara ini berfungsi ialah kita pertimbangkan masalah pertengahan yang dikenali sebagai masalah pencarian tertib.
Kita akan tengok macam mana kita boleh selesaikan
masalah pencarian tertib menggunakan anggaran fasa, dan kemudian kita akan bincang secara ringkas macam mana menyelesaikan masalah pencarian tertib
membolehkan kita memfaktorkan integer dengan cekap.
Bahagian kedua adalah sepenuhnya klasik dan saya hanya akan ringkaskan
idea asas dalam video ini.
Tapi jom mulakan dengan
masalah pencarian tertib.
Pertama, jom susun
notasi yang berguna.
Untuk setiap integer positif N, kita definisikan ZN sebagai integer
sifar hingga N tolak satu.
Jadi misalnya, Z satu mempunyai satu
elemen iaitu sifar, Z dua mempunyai elemen sifar dan satu,
z tiga mempunyai elemen sifar,
satu dan dua, dan seterusnya.
Jadi ZN adalah set.
Tapi kita juga boleh fikirkan tentang
ia lebih daripada sekadar set. Kita boleh fikirkan tentang operasi aritmetik seperti penambahan dan pendaraban pada ZN
dengan mendefinisikannya modular N.
Contohnya, jom andaikan
N sama dengan tujuh.
Kita ada bahawa tiga dan lima
adalah elemen Z tujuh dan kalau kita darabkan mereka kita dapat 15
yang meninggalkan baki satu
selepas dibahagi dengan tujuh.
Kadang-kadang kita nyatakan ini dengan menulis bahawa tiga kali lima adalah
kongruen dengan satu modulo tujuh, macam yang ditulis di sini.
Tapi kita juga boleh cuma tulis bahawa tiga kali lima sama dengan satu.
Sudah tentu tiga kali lima
bukan normalnya sama dengan satu, ia sama dengan 15.
Tapi bila jelas bahawa
kita sedang bekerja dalam Z tujuh bermakna pendaraban
didefinisikan modular tujuh,
kita boleh cuma tulis bahawa
tiga kali lima sama dengan satu.
Sekarang antara elemen
ZN untuk mana-mana N positif, sebahagian daripada mereka akan ada
GCD sama dengan satu dengan N
dan sebahagian tak. Dan elemen yang ada GCD sama dengan satu dengan N adalah istimewa.
dan kita tulis ZN bintang untuk merujuk kepada set hanya elemen-elemen ini.
Jadi misalnya, inilah Z 21 bintang.
antara elemen Z 21, yang ada 21 sudah tentu, rupanya 12 daripadanya ada GcD sama dengan satu
dengan 21 dan selebihnya tak.
Khususnya setiap kali
kita ada elemen Z 21 yang boleh dibahagi dengan sama ada
tiga atau tujuh, kita langkaukannya.
Ada pelbagai sebab
kenapa set ini istimewa, dan salah satu sebabnya ialah setiap kali kita ada elemen ZN bintang
dan kita pertimbangkan kuasa
integer positif nombor itu, kita akan sentiasa akhirnya
capai nombor satu,
di mana macam sebelum ni kita bercakap tentang pendaraban modular N.
kuasa integer positif terkecil yang memberi kita satu dipanggil
tertib elemen itu.
Contohnya, fikirkan tentang elemen A sama dengan empat dalam Z 21 bintang.
empat kali empat adalah 16, yang tidak sama dengan satu modular 21, tapi kalau kita darab dengan empat satu kali lagi,
kita dapat 64, dan 64 modular
21 sama dengan satu.
Jadi tertib empat modular 21 adalah tiga.
Sampai ke satu macam ni sentiasa berlaku untuk semua elemen ZN bintang.
Dan by the way, ia tak pernah
berlaku untuk elemen ZN yang bukan dalam ZN bintang.
Jadi ada GCD sama dengan
satu dengan N macam ni adalah kedua-duanya perlu dan
mencukupi untuk ini berlaku.
Dan cuma untuk habiskan
contoh N sama dengan 21, inilah kuasa integer positif terkecil yang mana ini berfungsi untuk
setiap elemen Z 21 bintang,
dan semuanya boleh disemak satu per satu.
Dan sekarang kita boleh nyatakan
masalah pencarian tertib, yang adalah cuma untuk cari tertib bagi elemen tertentu dalam ZN bintang.
WEBVTT
Lebih tepat, inputnya adalah
dua integer positif A dan N yang mana GCDnya sama dengan satu,
dan outputnya adalah
integer positif terkecil R yang mana A kepada kuasa R adalah
kongruen dengan satu modular N,
atau secara setaraf
integer positif terkecil R yang mana A kepada R sama dengan satu.
Dengan mengandaikan kita buat aritmetik dalam ZN.
Ini dipercayai jadi
masalah yang sukar secara pengiraan, tiada algoritma klasik yang cekap
diketahui untuk menyelesaikannya.
Dan macam yang akan kita bincangkan masalah ini sekurang-kurangnya sesukar
pemfaktoran integer dalam erti kata kalau kita ada algoritma untuk menyelesaikan pencarian tertib,
kita akan dapat guna algoritma itu untuk selesaikan masalah pemfaktoran
integer dengan cekap.
Sebenarnya, ia pergi cara lain juga, bermakna kalau kamu kebetulan ada algoritma untuk pemfaktoran, kamu boleh gunakannya untuk selesaikan
masalah pencarian tertib.
Jadi dua masalah itu adalah
dalam erti kata tertentu setara dari segi
kesukaran pengiraan.
Sekarang kita akan tengok macam mana kita boleh selesaikan
masalah pencarian tertib pada komputer kuantum
menggunakan anggaran fasa.
Untuk buat hubungan antara masalah, jom bayangkan kita ada sistem yang set keadaan klasiknya adalah AN.
Untuk mana-mana pilihan elemen A dalam ZN bintang, kita akan definisikan operasi
MA macam yang ada di sini.
Dalam perkataan apa yang MA buat ialah darab dengan A, dan di sini pendaraban adalah modular N.
Dan untuk baki pelajaran ini, kamu sepatutnya sentiasa fikirkan tentang
ungkapan dalam cat sebagai dikira modular N,
cuma supaya kita boleh kekalkan perkara mudah dan kita tak perlu terus
tulis mod N berulang kali.
Ini adalah operasi unitary, tapi itu cuma benar
sebab A ada dalam ZN bintang.
Kalau GCD A dan N bukan satu, operasi ini tak akan jadi unitary.
Inilah contoh. Kalau N sama dengan 15 dan A sama dengan dua, yang ada dalam Z 15 bintang, maka
inilah tindakan M dua.
Dan kalau kamu periksa
contoh ini seketika, kamu akan nampak bahawa apa yang berlaku ialah elemen ZN cuma dipermutasikan oleh tindakan ini.
Jadi ia kedua-duanya deterministik dan unitary, yang bermaksud bahawa sebagai matriks, MA adalah matriks permutasi.
Dan inilah idea utama. Eigenvalue MA sangat rapat berkait
dengan tertib A. Dan dengan menggunakan anggaran fasa untuk menganggarkan eigenvalue ini cukup hampir
kita boleh tentukan tertib A. Jadi apakah sebenarnya eigenvector dan eigenvalue MA?
Nah, kita tak perlukan semua daripada mereka, kita cuma perlukan sebahagian daripada mereka.
Jom mulakan dengan contoh mudah.
Inilah eigenvector MA, kita namakannya saiz sifar, dan ia diberikan oleh
jumlah cat satu, cat a,
cat A kuasa dua, dan seterusnya hingga cat A kepada kuasa R tolak satu, semuanya dibahagi dengan punca kuasa dua R
untuk jadikannya vektor unit. Di sini R adalah tertib A.
Dan saya akan simpan
huruf R untuk tertib A untuk selebihnya pelajaran.
Jadi bila-bila masa kamu nampak R, itulah tertib A untuk
A yang mana-mana yang kita bercakap tentang.
Eigenvalue yang berkaitan
dengan eigenvector ini adalah satu.
Dan kita boleh sahkan itu dengan
menerapkan MA kepada vektor ini untuk tengok apa yang kita dapat.
MA darab dengan A, jadi
kita cuma perlu tambah satu kepada setiap eksponen dan inilah yang kita dapat.
Tapi tertib A adalah R, jadi A kepada kuasa R sama dengan satu.
Dan kita boleh buat penggantian itu.
Tapi itulah vektor yang sama
yang kita mulakan. Kita cuma mengubah kedudukan cat tetapi kita sedang mengambil jumlah jadi
ini tak mengubah apa-apa.
Jadi MA kali psi sifar sama dengan psi sifar.
Jadi ia adalah eigenvector
MA dengan eigenvalue satu.
Itu adalah contoh yang sangat mudah
eigenvector dan untuk kenal pasti lebih daripada mereka, jom ingat semula notasi yang sama yang kita ada lebih awal dalam pelajaran.
Omega R adalah nombor kompleks
pada bulatan unit yang kita dapat dengan mengambil E kepada
kuasa dua kali pi kali I
dibahagi R. Kali lepas kita ada N bukannya R, tapi ia masih berfungsi sama
cara untuk R sebagai ganti N.
Kita perlukan nombor ini sebab
ia akan muncul dalam eigenvector
MA lain yang akan kita kenal pasti.
Dan sekarang kita dah ingat semula notasi itu, kita boleh perhatikan bahawa
vektor bernama psi satu ini juga adalah eigenvector MA.
Ia serupa dengan psi sifar, kita ada tepat cat yang sama dan kita menjumlahkan mereka dan
membahagi dengan punca kuasa dua R.
Tapi kali ni kita ada pelbagai fasa yang darab setiap cat.
Omega R kepada kuasa negatif satu untuk A, omega R kepada kuasa negatif dua untuk A kuasa dua, dan seterusnya hingga omega R kepada
kuasa negatif R tolak satu
untuk A kepada kuasa R tolak satu. Jadi kuasa omega R
sentiasa negatif satu kali kuasa A apa pun
yang muncul dalam cat.
Saya tak akan pergi melaluinya dengan terperinci, tapi ia ditunjukkan pada skrin kalau kamu nak tonton semula video dan berhenti seketika bila perlu.
Tapi kalau kita buat pendaraban dan kita permudahkan sekali lagi menggunakan fakta bahawa A kepada kuasa R sama dengan satu
serta fakta yang sangat penting bahawa omega kepada kuasa R sama dengan satu, apa yang kita akan jumpa ialah kita
sekali lagi ada eigenvector MA.
WEBVTT
Kali ini bila kita buat pemudahan, kita perlu tarik keluar faktor omega R untuk nampak bahawa memang kita ada eigenvector
dan vektor omega R itu mewakili eigenvalue yang berkaitan dengan eigenvector ini.
Jadi itulah pasangan eigenvector
eigenvalue kedua NA.
Kita boleh kenal pasti eigenvector tambahan menggunakan penaakulan yang sama, Dan sebenarnya, kalau kita cuma gantikan omega R
dengan omega R kepada kuasa J untuk setiap J antara sifar dan R tolak satu, kita akan sentiasa dapat eigenvector,
dan eigenvalue yang berkaitan akan jadi omega R kepada kuasa J.
Jadi ini sebenarnya termasuk
psi sifar dan pis satu, yang dah kita lihat
serta R tolak dua, pasangan eigenvector eigenvalue lain.
Semuanya berfungsi pada asasnya dengan cara yang sama, dan untuk sahkannya, kita cuma perlu tahu bahawa A kepada kuasa R sama dengan satu
serta omega R kepada
kuasa R sama dengan satu.
Ada eigenvector lain MA macam cat sifar misalnya, tapi ia tak akan berguna kepada kita dan kita tak perlu risau tentang mereka.
Kita cuma perlu risau tentang psi sifar hingga psi R tolak satu.
Jom fokus pada psi satu seketika, cuma untuk cuba faham kenapa kita ambil berat tentang eigenvector ini
dan apa yang ia boleh beritahu
kita tentang tertib R, yang merupakan apa yang kita cuba cari.
Andaikan kita diberi
eigenvector psi satu, kita boleh cuba pelajari
R dengan cara berikut.
Pertama, kita laksanakan anggaran
fasa ke atas eigenvector ini menggunakan quantum circuit yang
melaksanakan operasi MA.
Apa yang kita dapat ialah anggaran theta, yang adalah satu dibahagi R dalam kes ini.
Dan kedua sebab kita sedang cari R dan kita ada
anggaran untuk satu dibahagi R, benda semula jadi untuk buat ialah
kira salingan
dan bulatkannya kepada
integer terdekat. Kita kena bulatkan macam ni
sebab R mestilah integer.
Tapi kita tak ada satu dibahagi R dengan tepat, kita cuma ada anggaran untuk itu.
Tapi kalau anggaran itu cukup bagus, kita akan dapat R bila kita bulatkan,
yang merupakan apa yang kita cari.
Dan sekarang soalannya ialah berapa banyak ketepatan yang kita perlukan untuk tentukan R dengan betul dengan mengira salingan dan membundarkan?
Atau dalam erti kata lain, seberapa tepat anggaran kita perlu jadi untuk buat semua ini berfungsi?
Nah, rupanya kita memang perlukan anggaran yang agak tepat.
Contohnya, kita tak boleh
sanggup kelirukan satu dibahagi R dengan satu dibahagi R tambah satu, atau satu dibahagi R tolak satu misalnya.
Dalam dua pecahan itu, satu dibahagi R tambah satu dan
satu dibahagi R tolak satu adalah agak hampir kepada satu
dibahagi R bila R besar.
Tapi walaupun kita memang perlukan
anggaran yang agak tepat, kita tak perlukan anggaran yang luar biasa tepat, dan boleh ditunjukkan bahawa kalau anggaran kita
memenuhi ketaksamaan yang
kita ada di sini pada skrin, maka pembundaran akan
memberi kita jawapan yang betul.
Saya tak akan cuba berhujah itu dalam video ini, tapi ia ditunjukkan dalam
bahan bertulis untuk pelajaran kalau kamu berminat dengan butiran.
Dan kalau itulah ketepatan
yang kita tuju, maka memadai untuk guna
bilangan control qubit dalam prosedur anggaran fasa
yang sama dengan dua kali
panjang N tambah satu.
Di mana macam yang kita ada dalam pelajaran sebelumnya, panjang N adalah bilangan bit yang kita perlukan untuk nyatakan N dalam perduaan.
By the way, kalau kita berpuas hati
untuk mendapat anggaran terbaik dengan kebarangkalian sekurang-kurangnya 40% dan kita tak cuba untuk
tingkatkan keyakinan kita
macam yang saya huraikan lebih awal, maka kita sebenarnya tak perlukan tambah satu itu.
Tapi dalam mana-mana kes, kita ada bahawa bilangan
control qubit yang kita perlukan adalah linear dalam panjang N
yang ditulis sebagai rentetan perduaan.
Kita dah nampak bahawa kalau kita ada
eigenvector psi satu, kita boleh guna anggaran fasa untuk cari R, asalkan kita guna ketepatan yang mencukupi.
Sayangnya ia tak begitu mudah untuk dapatkan eigenvector ini.
Jadi jom tanya soalan yang berbeza.
Andaikan kita tak ada psi satu, tapi sebaliknya kita ada psi
untuk pilihan J yang rawak.
Bolehkah kita masih cari tahu apa R? Atau sekurang-kurangnya bolehkah kita
cari tahu sesuatu tentang R?
Dan jawapannya ialah ya, kita boleh cari tahu sesuatu
tentang R, sekurang-kurangnya secara purata.
Apa yang boleh kita buat ialah cuba
cari tahu J dibahagi R menggunakan kaedah yang sangat serupa
dengan yang baru kita lihat,
tapi dengan perbezaan utama.
Pertama, kita akan buat tepat
perkara yang sama yang kita buat sebelum ni, iaitu jalankan prosedur
anggaran fasa ke atas eigenvector psi J.
Dan apa yang kita akan dapat ialah
anggaran kepada J dibahagi R, berbanding satu dibahagi R,
yang merupakan apa yang kita ada sebelum ni.
Tapi sekarang kita ada masalah kecil, sebab mengira
salingan tak akan memberi kita R, ia akan memberi kita R dibahagi J.
Dan by the way, kita tak
mengandaikan bahawa kita tahu apa J, kita cuma diberi psi J untuk J yang rawak,
dan kita tak diberitahu apa J. Jadi apa yang boleh kita buat?
Nah, rupanya ada
algoritma klasik yang terkenal yang boleh bantu kita, yang dipanggil
algoritma pecahan berterusan.
Dan apa yang algoritma ini boleh buat ialah mengambil anggaran kita
Y dibahagi dua kepada M dan beritahu kita pecahan mana U dibahagi V,
yang ditulis dalam sebutan paling rendah, dan di mana U dan V kedua-duanya
integer lebih kecil daripada N, yang paling hampir kepada anggaran kita.
WEBVTT
Ia adalah algoritma yang benar-benar menarik, dan kalau kamu berminat dengannya, kamu semestinya semaknya.
Ia sangat rapat berkait dengan algoritma Euclid untuk
mengira GCD sebenarnya.
Tapi saya tak akan cakap apa-apa
lebih lanjut tentangnya dalam video ini.
Intinya ialah kalau kita ada
anggaran yang bagus kepada sesetengah pecahan yang pengangka dan
penyebutnya tak terlalu besar,
algoritma boleh pulihkan pecahan itu, dan itulah yang kita buat di sini.
Dan sekarang kita tinggal dengan tepat
soalan yang sama seperti sebelumnya, iaitu berapa banyak ketepatan yang kita perlukan?
Dan rupanya
tepat sempadan yang sama yang kita ada sebelumnya berfungsi dalam kes ini.
Dan jadi memilih M dengan tepat
cara yang sama seperti sebelumnya berfungsi di sini juga.
Sekarang ini tak semestinya
memberitahu kita R.
Apa yang kita akan pelajari kalau kita guna
ketepatan yang mencukupi, adalah J dibahagi R, tapi itu akan jadi
pecahan dalam sebutan paling rendah.
Jadi kita mungkin tak bernasib baik dalam erti kata pilihan J rawak ini mungkin ada faktor sepunya dengan R,
dan ia akan tersembunyi dari kita. Dalam kes paling teruk misalnya, kita boleh dapat J sama dengan sifar dan kita tak akan pelajari sama sekali apa-apa.
Tapi itulah secara harfiahnya satu-satunya
kes di mana kita tak pelajari apa-apa.
Secara umum, kita akan sekurang-kurangnya
mendapat faktor bukan remeh R, dan kalau kita boleh ambil sampel rawak
dan dapat psi J untuk pilihan J yang berbeza, kita sebenarnya boleh pulihkan
R dengan kebarangkalian tinggi dengan mengira gandaan sepunya terkecil
semua penyebut
yang kita perhatikan. Dan ini sebenarnya tak
memerlukan sangat banyak sampel pun.
Kesimpulannya ialah sesetengah pilihan J akan menyembunyikan faktor R, tapi pilihan J rawak
tak akan dapat menyembunyikan
faktor R untuk lama.
Jadi itulah ideanya. Ia masih perlu pertimbangkan pelaksanaan dan khususnya untuk cari tahu
berapa kos yang diperlukan.
Inti ideanya, untuk kira tertib
elemen A tertentu dan ZN bintang ialah menerapkan prosedur anggaran fasa
kepada operasi MA.
Jom cari tahu apa
kos melakukan ini sebagai fungsi panjang N huruf besar, yang saya akan tandakan dengan n huruf kecil.
Inilah circuit untuk anggaran fasa. Kita akan perlukan n huruf kecil qubit pada bahagian bawah circuit
untuk kodkan elemen ZN dalam perduaan. Jadi kita ada N control qubit di atas dan n huruf kecil qubit di bawah,
yang bagus sebab itu sepadan dengan nama yang
kita guna lebih awal dalam pelajaran.
Untuk kira
bilangan gate yang kita perlukan untuk keseluruhan circuit, jom fokus dahulu pada kos operasi unitary yang dikawal.
Kalau kita guna teknik
dari pelajaran sebelumnya, pelajaran enam, kita boleh laksanakan MA menggunakan O besar daripada n huruf kecil kuasa dua gate
menggunakan algoritma klasik yang cekap untuk aritmetik modular N.
Saya akan langkau butiran dalam video ini, tapi macam beberapa perkara lain yang saya bercakap tentang, kamu boleh baca lebih lanjut tentangnya dalam bahan bertulis untuk pelajaran.
Tak mencukupi bagaimanapun
untuk laksanakan MA sahaja.
Kita juga perlu laksanakan MA kuasa dua, MA kepada kuasa empat, kepada
kuasa lapan, dan seterusnya
sehinggalah MA kepada kuasa yang eksponen dalam M.
Dan kita tahu kita perlu ambil M jadi linear dalam n huruf kecil
untuk dapat ketepatan yang mencukupi.
Ini adalah kebimbangan besar,
dan saya bangkitkannya lebih awal.
Kalau kita laksanakan kuasa
MA dengan cuma mengulang MA, kita akan ada masalah sebab semua iterasi MA
ini akan menanggung kos eksponen.
Nasib baik, kita boleh guna trick untuk elak peningkatan kos ini.
Apa yang boleh kita buat adalah macam berikut, untuk setiap kuasa K yang kita perlukan.
Pertama, kita kira A kepada
kuasa K, modular N.
Ini adalah masalah pemangkatan modular yang saya sebut dalam pelajaran enam.
Dan ia boleh diselesaikan dengan cekap. Dan ini adalah sesuatu yang boleh kita buat dengan komputer klasik.
Pengiraan ini tak
perlu dilaksanakan oleh quantum circuit pun.
Jadi jom biarkan B menjadi hasilnya.
Jadi B adalah elemen ZN bintang.
Dan kedua, sebagai ganti MA kepada kuasa K, kita cuma guna circuit untuk MB.
Dan itulah sahaja. B cuma sesetengah elemen ZN bintang, Jadi kos untuk laksanakan MB
adalah O besar daripada n huruf kecil kuasa dua.
Dalam ringkasannya, apa yang kita buat ialah pemangkatan dalam ZN bukannya pemangkatan
quantum circuit.
Tapi operasi sebenar yang kita
dapat adalah sama dalam kedua-dua cara. Ia cuma pendaraban dengan A, K kali.
Ini sebenarnya semacam keajaiban. Dan kita tak akan dapat
menyelesaikan masalah pencarian tertib atau memfaktorkan integer dengan cekap
dengan komputer kuantum
kalau bukan kerana ini.
Dan sekarang kita tahu bahawa setiap
operasi unitary yang dikawal, termasuk kuasa, boleh dilaksanakan
pada kos O besar n kuasa dua, kita boleh kira jumlah
bilangan gate yang kita perlukan.
Kita ada N Hadamard gate, dan sebab M sama dengan
O besar daripada n huruf kecil, kosnya adalah O besar daripada n huruf kecil.
WEBVTT
Kita ada M operasi unitary yang dikawal yang setiap satu ada kos O besar daripada N kuasa dua.
Jadi jumlah kos di sini
adalah O besar daripada N kuasa tiga.
Dan akhirnya, transformasi Fourier kuantum ada kos O besar daripada n kuasa dua.
Jadi jumlah kos adalah O besar daripada N kuasa tiga.
Khususnya, kita nampak bahawa walaupun dengan
trick pemangkatan modular kita, kos operasi
unitary yang dikawal masih mendominasi.
Tapi pun begitu, kos
adalah polinomial dalam n huruf kecil.
Ada juga beberapa
pengiraan klasik yang diperlukan, macam mengira pemangkatan modular dan menjalankan algoritma pecahan berterusan,
tapi pengiraan-pengiraan itu
juga ada kos polinomial. Dan sebenarnya, ia boleh dilakukan dalam operasi O besar daripada N kuasa tiga juga.
Tinggal satu isu lagi sahaja, iaitu kita perlu dapatkan salah satu daripada eigenvector ini.
Macam mana kita boleh buat ni?
Penyelesaiannya sebenarnya sangat mudah. Kita tak jalankan circuit
ke atas eigenvector.
Kita cuma jalankannya ke atas keadaan satu, bermaksud pengekodan perduaan
nombor satu, yang kita fikirkan
sebagai elemen ZN.
Jadi jom buat
penggantian itu dalam diagram.
Sebab ini berfungsi adalah kerana persamaan ini di sini.
Keadaan cat satu sebenarnya adalah
superposisi seragam R eigenvector yang
kita bercakap tentang.
Dan itu tak jelas segera, tapi kalau kamu kira
jumlah, kamu patut dapat cat satu.
Dan kalau kita jalankan circuit ke atas keadaan ini, output yang kita akan dapat
adalah tepat sama seperti kalau kita memilih J secara rawak
dan jalankan prosedur ke atas
eigenvector psi J.
Sekali lagi, itu tak jelas, tapi analisis mendedahkan ia adalah benar.
Dan akhirnya, itulah sahaja. Kita ada algoritma kuantum
yang cekap untuk pencarian tertib.
Ada satu bahagian yang sangat pendek
pelajaran yang tinggal dan ia berkenaan hubungan antara pemfaktoran integer
dan pencarian tertib.
Saya sebut bahawa kalau kita boleh selesaikan masalah pencarian tertib dengan cekap, maka kita juga boleh memfaktorkan
integer dengan cekap.
Dan saya nak bagi kamu secara ringkas idea utama macam mana ini berfungsi.
Ia sepenuhnya klasik. Bahagian ini sebenarnya tiada
kena mengena dengan pengkomputeran kuantum.
Inilah kaedah untuk cari
faktor bukan remeh bagi integer positif N tertentu.
Dan by the way, kaedah ini cuma berfungsi bila N adalah nombor ganjil, dan ia bukan
nombor perdana yang dinaikkan kepada kuasa.
Dua kes itu bila N
adalah genap atau kuasa perdana boleh ditangani secara berasingan.
Ada kaedah klasik yang cekap untuk kedua-dua mengesan dan
menangani dua kes tersebut.
Kaedah ini adalah kebarangkalian. Ia mungkin gagal, tapi
kebarangkalian kegagalan akan paling banyak setengah,
dan kita boleh cuma jalankannya
beberapa kali secara bebas untuk kurangkan kebarangkalian
ralat dengan cepat secara eksponen.
Pertama, kita pilih A antara
dua dan N tolak satu secara rawak, secara seragam.
Kemudian kita kira GCD A dan N.
Dan kalau GCD kebetulan
lebih besar daripada satu, maka kita baru sahaja sangat bertuah.
GCD akan jadi faktor N dan kita boleh cuma outputkannya dan berhenti.
Kalau tidak, algoritma berterusan dan sekarang kita tahu bahawa A ada dalam ZN bintang.
Dan sekarang kita kira tertib A, yang merupakan tempat kita perlukan komputer kuantum.
Atau mungkin kita ada cara lain
untuk kira tertib. Algoritma tak terlalu kisah dari mana datangnya, tapi satu-satunya cara yang kita tahu
macam mana nak buat ini dengan cekap
adalah dengan komputer kuantum.
Kalau tertib R adalah genap, maka kita kira GCD
A kepada kuasa R dibahagi dua tolak satu dengan N.
Dan kalau GCD itu lebih besar daripada satu, maka sekali lagi kita ada faktor N, jadi kita outputkannya dan kita berhenti.
Kalau tidak algoritma telah gagal. Dan dalam kes itu, kita
boleh kembali ke permulaan dan pilih A yang berbeza
dan berharap untuk hasil yang lebih baik
kali seterusnya.
Dan itulah sahaja. Dan by the way, bila kita
dah jumpa faktor N, kita boleh rekurs pada faktor itu
dan bahagi dengannya sehingga kita ada pemfaktoran perdana N.
Jadi kenapa ini patut berfungsi?
Nah, ada dua perkara utama. Yang pertama ialah sebab A kepada kuasa R adalah kongruen dengan satu modular N,
kita ada bahawa N membahagi A
kepada kuasa R tolak satu.
Dua pernyataan itu
sebenarnya setara. Ini adalah definisi mod N yang kamu akan jumpa dalam buku teori nombor.
Kedua, kalau R adalah genap, maka persamaan yang
kita ada di sini adalah benar.
Ini adalah formula yang terkenal
untuk beza kuasa dua.
Sebenarnya, persamaan itu adalah benar untuk semua R, tapi kita perlukan R dibahagi dua jadi integer dalam langkah empat.
WEBVTT
Dan jadi kalau kita gabungkan dua fakta, kita nampak bahawa setiap faktor perdana N mestilah membahagi salah satu daripada dua
ungkapan dalam kurungan,
sebab itulah satu-satunya cara
N boleh membahagi hasilnya.
Sekarang, mungkin sahaja bahawa setiap
faktor perdana tunggal N membahagi ungkapan pertama dalam kurungan dan bukan yang kedua, tapi untuk A rawak kita,
itu tak begitu berkemungkinan. Dan jadi bila kita kira
GCD dalam langkah empat, kita berkemungkinan untuk mendapat hasilnya
sebahagian faktor perdana
N, tapi bukan semua.
Untuk menganalisis ini dengan teliti
memerlukan beberapa teori nombor, tapi ia adalah teori nombor yang agak asas.
Jadi kalau kamu rasa
teori nombor menarik dan kamu nak pelajari lebih lanjut tentangnya, cuba buat analisis ini.
Buat perkara-perkara macam ni adalah cara terbaik untuk belajar lebih lanjut, tapi saya akan tinggalkan itu kepada kamu.
Dan itulah akhir pelajaran. Dalam pelajaran ini, kita bincangkan
masalah anggaran fasa, macam mana kita boleh selesaikannya dengan cekap
pada komputer kuantum,
dan macam mana kita boleh terapkan penyelesaian untuk mendapat algoritma kuantum
kos polinomial untuk pemfaktoran integer.
Harap kamu akan sertai saya untuk pelajaran seterusnya, yang berkenaan algoritma
carian kuantum Grover.
Selamat tinggal sampai jumpa lagi.